I have to ask you this question before  we go there's a rumor out there maybe  just a rumor that you might possibly be  up next to play James Bond anything you  can say about that I could say two  things I'm English mm-hmm and I look  definitely handsome in a suit yes I  could say three things and nobody has  called me so I'm pretty sure that's not  gonna happen  well they're calling me non-stop they're  yeah they want to go a different way  with bond apparently if then you decide  not to do it you could just throw your  old pal Charlie's name in the hats all  right I'll consider you look handy I've  been asking to so you know I would make  a formidable bombs yeah he would it's  like bond after he took a few years off  I think it'd be a great bond  you